[Music]
morning
[Music]
time to go make a movie
with Babylon I wanted to capture in
those early days of Hollywood in a
really unvarnished unsanitized way
it's the most magical place in the world
Kodak was an amazing partner helping us
shoot for perf 35 millimeter film and
we'll shoot the amount of film we needed
to shoot for such an expansive epic
there's something magical to do a film
about your own industry as well and
action so Babylon had to be filmed this
business started on film it felt like
the only natural way to represent the
spirit of those people were how they
were making films
was insane take two frames off the tail
and three more up the head cleanness
takes us on an incredible visual journey
I like to get what I get in camera
in Babylon we didn't really follow any
rules
treated the film dramatically on day
exteriors I wanted to feel really
deserty and pale because I Overexposed
like three to four stops and push
process that treatment on digital camera
would just look Overexposed and bright
shooting on film helps to make a more
emotional connection with the audience
gotta map those dreams onto celluloids
and print them into history well the
Hope was to make something that felt
like a roller coaster filled with Vivid
characters spectacle excess one to one
panoramic canvas at the end of the day
Kodak film just lent itself to that
aesthetic when I shoot on film I kind of
always know exactly how it's gonna look
and then when I get the dailies back
it's always a little better
[Music]
oh yes you'll never forget it